hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel so it came up on a live stream
recently that I used to work at Gamestop
I worked up for like four or five years
and ever more exactly it was my second
job and people had a lot of questions
about this experience so it was back in
Australia where it is called EB Games
but it's still the same company
basically game still bought out EB Games
in the entirety of Australia but kept
the name because it had more brand
recognition that basically and I worked
it from when I was like 14 to 18 I think
and I'm gonna use this video to tell
some horror stories and some of the
worst things about working that because
that's what everyone keeps asking me
about but I do want to start this video
by saying that I really really enjoyed
some of the aspects of working then my
favorite thing and I still kind of
missed this was having a parent or
brother or sister or a boyfriend or
girlfriend come into the store and try
and buy a gift for someone and need my
help
and be like hey this person that I'm
trying to buy a birthday present for
loves halo and then I like what with him
super hard to be like well what do they
like about halo is it because it's a
shooter do they play it for the
multiplayer don't they like the sci-fi
would they be into Mass Effect and it
was just like this huge thing of me like
trying to figure these people's
interests out to get them the right game
and I had it so much fun doing that that
was like probably the only pot that I
found fun so I actually got the job
because they had games up on a like demo
station and I would just come in every
single afternoon on to school and play
whatever was new there so I was just
like in the stove all the time thinking
about it now just kind of loitering
really and eventually the guy who was
the manager was like hey you wanna come
in for a trial you hear all the time
everyone he likes you while looking for
casuals to fill in over the holidays so
I went in for a trial got the job and
super quickly after that it turned out
that that manager was super incompetent
and an alcoholic so he was fired
replaced by a manager from another store
who then laid off the entire staff
for me which just a terrible place to
sometimes a morale and they in clearly
picked her because the store was a mess
and needed work so she was like hot coal
and she was really strict about the
single worst thing about working there
which is kpi's basically when you go to
gamestop and they ask you if you have a
rewards card or they ask you if you want
to preorder anything or if you want any
accessories or if you want to buy the
game pre-owned instead of brand new
that's because the stats list it out and
has literally competitions internally in
the stores where they'll be like oh this
person got the most pre-owned is this
week good job why didn't you get as many
as them so if that asking you those
questions it's because there's so much
pressure from the top and I understand
kpi's but the way that was dealt with so
competitively was really gross in my
opinion to the extent that they would
encourage us to do some shady [ __ ] they
would encourage me to sell a pre-owned
up for a game that had just been
announced meaning it didn't even have a
release date that was once a legitimate
conversation that was along the lines of
if someone's buying a shooter you should
tell them that you've seen the latest
Call of Duty and you know that it's
awesome to encourage them to preorder it
even though you haven't I do look at two
of the store was like one that I would
fill in and one that I ended up being a
casual app that didn't tell me a lie
about [ __ ] but they was still just so
strict about kpi's in a way that just
never felt fair aside from that and I
mean I like not spent a lot of time
talking about this pod the walkouts was
just terrible in that you would have to
do tons of unpaid overtime even as
casual stuff you know I was like a 15
year old working in a store being told
to stay two hours late which is illegal
and thinking about it now the fact that
it happened to me when I was effectively
a child just seems so much more messed
up anytime there was a sale we would
have to make sure the stickers had been
changed on every single game before the
end of the 90
you said that one time my nail blood
from peeling stickers off of cases for
so long I started bleeding and I was
still bad doing it not getting paid for
it so yeah totally
shady working conditions but then there
were the customers which was next level
I don't even know where to start
there was this weird thing in the city
that I lived in don't know if this
happens in other cities or other stores
where people who are in some way
involved in selling drugs would you know
sell the drugs and trade them for an
Xbox and then they were using Xboxes and
Playstations kind of as currency in
these drug schemes so we would have the
same person come in multiple times
trading in a console or returning a
console and we would have to basically
take down notes for police reports that
we're looking for these people it was
hectic we would also sometimes have
people who would go up to games on the
shelf and swap the price sticker over
because I guess there's a law in
Australia where if something has the
wrong sticker on it on the wrong price
on it you have to sell it for the listed
price so we would watch people will take
off a sticker and swap it with another
sticker and then come to the count and
be like oh I would like to buy this game
and then you have to really quietly be
like oh I'm sorry um I just saw you swap
the stick is over I'm gonna have to give
it to you for the original price the
absolute was thing that happened a
million times was when a kid would come
into the store and try and buy an MA 15
plus game and you would have to tell
them no because they will underage you
have to check for ID and be like I can't
legally sell you this game because it is
rated higher than your age and then they
would leave and they would bring their
parents back with them and their parents
would just yell at you they would yell
at you for not selling the kid a game
that you legally couldn't sell them well
actually a child is 13 this is rated
full audiences over 15 years old because
it deals with mature themes are you
aware of it they just would just
lose their minds at you it was like you
were the biggest inconvenience in the
world because parents wouldn't do their
research on what kind of games that kid
was trying to buy it was just like
people had utter disregard for the fact
that part of your job was upholding the
law which is pretty unusual the same
thing happens with traded games you
can't accept trade-ins from anyone
unless that River 18 and I mean that was
a whole other story when you would tell
them that the price wasn't as high as
they expected like that's a meme or just
be so mad at you like you were the one
picking the goddamn prices like it
wasn't something that was set in stone
by the people at the head code is making
a hundred thousand dollars a year I did
also deal with like crappy behavior from
people being like oh you're a girl like
is there a man here I can speak to about
the video games oh like young guys guys
with teenagers just like completely
doubting my knowledge that stuff's
mostly laughable but also like sometimes
it's kind of fun when people would be
like oh is there a man around and I'd be
like I can grab one for you but try me
but hey all of that said then what parts
of it that I really enjoyed I liked a
lot of the people that I worked with
single best thing about working that was
that you know there's huge posters I
don't like wall size that they have
hanging at game stops I have a
collection of so many of those
Assassin's Creed - I have the lost of us
I think I have gives three I've got a
halo one I think it's reach for halo I
have so many of those giant marketing
posters I love them so much that's still
back home in Australia my parents
actually recently asked if they could
throw them out but something about the
fact that they have the marketing stuff
like the release date on them I feel
like just makes them even more valuable
like I'm so attached to those but hey I
hope you guys found this video
interesting totally never come to me to
make one before you have any more
questions happy to answer them for you
and anyone else work there has more
horror stories you should totally share
them I will see you guys next time bye